only on CBS this morning we are hearing
from the parents of a British man killed
in a crash when an American woman was
driving the wrong way and cyclists
claimed diplomatic immunity and flew
back to the u.s. 19 year old Harry Dunne
died in August when a car leaving a US
military base in the UK hit his
motorcycle Dunn's parent Charlotte and
Tim have come to this country to share
their story we spoke to them earlier
this morning in their first TV interview
in the United States I know this is very
difficult we've all been following this
story and we're also very sorry that
this has happened to your family I want
to start with an cyclists who released a
statement over the weekend through her
attorney where she said she wants to
meet with Dunn's parents so that she can
express her deepest sympathies and
apologize for this tragic accident this
was the first time we've heard from her
what did you all think when you heard
her words Charlotte why is it taking so
long
you know it's seven weeks tomorrow we
lost our boy we feel that that statement
should have come out from her right from
the beginning instead of getting on a
plane and running home is there any part
of you that feels well maybe this is
very difficult for her too and she
didn't know what to do we and we
realized that obviously she may not have
been given any choice
as such under this supposed diplomatic
immunity cloak which we're not even sure
she did have your answer she even had
double sure one actually but we don't
believe she did and that's being looked
into as far as we're aware Tim I'm just
hearing this morning that you were able
to get to the accident scene shortly
after it happened and you got to see
your son how is it that you happen to
get there okay fortunately for me I have
a friend that works for our local fire
brigade that attended the scene because
obviously Parris motorbike was in flames
after the collision with the car and he
managed to get a message to me through
his wife who I work with and she said
there's been an accident and she
believed Harry was involved and there's
a only about three miles from where I
live
I just jumped in the car and went up
there then you saw him was he conscious
it's all right yes when I got there
there
paramedics were just putting him onto
the stretcher and pulling him out of the
grass verge I could see and broken bones
out of his arms and stuff but he was
talking he was talking was talking so he
knew you were there
he knew yeah I spoke to him I I called
over to him and said Perry is she dead
they're gonna fix you they're gonna fix
you be calm let them help you he he
stopped crying moaning because he was he
was he was complaining that he couldn't
breathe very well so he sort of calm
then and then a couple of months later
one of the doctors working on him came
to me and said he's struggling to
breathe so they were gonna sedate him so
I spoke to him again and said Harry
they're gonna sedate you now it's just
for your best you're gonna be okay we'll
see you later a hospital something I
said like that and then actually they
didn't and that was the last time you
can see clearly that it's still very
very painful and as painful as it was
both of them said that they were glad
that Tim got to see his son and
Charlotte the mom said because she knows
and Harry's final moments that the
father was there and gave her son
comfort it's very very difficult they
have a lot to say